[موسيقى]
وفي ناحيه اخرى من هذه المدينه يستقبل
اهالي وسكان هرار صديق المساء انها الضباع
تقطن هذه الضباع في الغابات والمزارع
المجاوره للمدينه فعلاقه سكان هرر بالضباع
تعود لاكثر من قرنين من الزمان حيث يذكر
سكان المدينه ان جفافا وقحطا قد حل مما
جعل الضباعه تهاجم السكان والماشيه فقرر
السكان توكيل شخص من بينهم يقوم باعطاء
الضباع ما بقي من طعامهم لتعقد هدنه
وصداقه بين الضباع وسكان هرر حتى يومنا
هذا
عمل
الجيوب لايه ورثت هذه المهنه من والدي
الذي قام باطعام هذه الضباع لاكثر من
اربعين سنه وانا منذ صغري اساعد والدي في
اطعامها مما جعلني اتمكن من التمييز بينهم
حسب اختلاف درجه الوانهم وعلى حسب طبائعهم
فهنالك من يستجيب للاوامر وهنالك من يتطفل
على طعام غيره
من ادابز